I think one of the things that is the
hardest thing about being a director
that there's that moment where you at
least when you're beginning and you
really want to because you do it's like
a family and you want to keep everybody
in the family happy and you want
everybody in the family to take care of
each other and you feel that you are the
one who's being you know taken to places
ahead of the family so you better be
responsible to everybody make sure
everybody's okay and I think one of the
hardest things is also your instinct to
when you have to push your family just
the the way you have to push them to say
this is not going to be easy when I
first started I wanted everybody to feel
like this is the greatest experience and
the greatest days of our life right and
then I realized you know what at the end
of the day there can be days that they
don't like me because I'd rather them
not like me and not have wasted five
months of their life because I want them
to be proud of the end result I know
that real leadership is pushing people
to do something that at the end of the
day they're happy they did and they're
proud of and they're happy to be a team
and work as a team